be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so as we continue our discussion on
Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four what
I'm thinking is that you guys are gonna
freak as we get to this video because if
you guys are anything like me I was
reading to this comic and I was like oh
my god then this is why I love Jonathan
Hickman writing so much because god he
knows how to tell one hell of a story so
in the last video we have talked about
how the old man Logan story dealt with
the death of all the superheroes and the
supervillains taking over the world and
at the end of that story
Wolverine had basically taken the son of
the Incredible Hulk as a newborn and
went forward with the intention of
creating a resistance to get rid of all
the supervillains and so what had
happened is in that reality the
supervillains were completely eliminated
and society began to go back to a state
of normalcy but the problem here is that
over time the earth began dying and so
the result was that those individuals in
the future though both superheroes and
normal humans had worked together to
create a portal to create a machine that
would allow them to travel into the past
in order to ensure their survival but in
order to power that machine they had to
take Galactus from the future kill him
and then use his power cosmic to power
the machine and so the result was that
once they achieved that goal the future
body of Galactus had fallen through the
rift
and landed in the present which was
discovered by Mole Man who informed Reed
Richards of what was going on and so
what we do is we pick up with this and
that Silver Surfer had discovered that
Reed Richards bury the body of future
Galactus and Silver Surfer reported back
to Galactus what it was that he had
found something because this was such an
important situation and so what happens
here is that Galactus from the present
simply shows up on the planet earth and
this is so cool because he doesn't go
through a whole bunch of introductions
he doesn't do any threatening he simply
just shows up to Reed Richards when Reed
Richards appears to me Galactus and
Galactus just says explained and this I
think is one of the perfect examples
it's so cool how hitman takes concepts
takes like all these thoughts and
emotions and feelings and throws them
into a simple word because when Galactus
just shows up and says explain it
denotes authority it denotes if you
don't give me what I want to know
I'm going to destroy your world I mean
it's it's such a cool series of things
that go into this but what Reed does is
he effectively tells Galactus exactly
what I just said a second ago about the
future of the old man Logan universe and
the travel through time and the result
is that read says that for him it just
seemed right to bury that version of
Galactus it didn't seem right to simply
just leave his decaying corpse on the
surface of the world now while Reed
doesn't necessarily say it either I
would imagine that to a degree that
would be panic if for example the
Avengers were just traveling around the
world or if the x-men were just
traveling around the world doing
whatever the Avengers and the x-men do
and they're often and they stumbled
across the decaying corpse of Galactus
on the surface of the planet they would
probably start freaking out and they
would be like oh my god Galactus is dead
and who knows who did it and it would
turn into a great big huge thing pencil
is probably cut trying to eliminate
panic you know more or less but the fact
remains here that once Galactus is
informed of everything that's going on
by read he tells the Silver Surfer to
locate the new world that Reed had put
the survivors on and sent them off to
and so one Silver Surfer locates a new
world he tells Galactus exactly where it
is and Galactus says that they're
immediately going to leave and they're
going to go fine new world and
investigate for themselves now this is
all extremely important and the reason
why is because this deals directly with
Franklin Richards and this tells us why
Galactus is afraid of Franklin Richards
what we find out is that with Johnny
storm showing up and trying to figure
things out trying to understand whether
or not he needs to react in a defensive
or an office and pasady when Reed tells
Johnny that he's going to leave with
Galactus there's really no discussion
here there's no debate there's no well
less talk things out and figure things
out Galactus wants to find out what's
going on Reed's gonna go with him and
there's no two ways about it and so what
happens is that once the two take off
once a Silver Surfer goes with Galactus
and Reed Richards to find out what's
going on in new world we pick up with
new world but something interesting to
note here this is why I say this is all
about Franklin Richards is because when
they arrive Galactus makes mention to
read about how fast he had left earth
and Reed says yes he noticed that but he
figured that if Galactus was leaving the
earth faster than normal it was probably
a reason why and Reed was simply going
to wait and see whether or not that
reason revealed itself but instead
Galactus tells him to
what he says is that he left the planet
Earth in order to avoid a conflict that
could have been catastrophic on a
universal scale meaning they could have
laid waste to the universe and when Reid
asked what it is that galactus is
talking about Galactus says that the
barriers and Franklin Richards mind have
been removed which of course was done by
his future self and that Reid and
Galactus need to talk about Franklin now
again this is a really big deal because
Galactus says that he was afraid
basically he left the planet Earth
because he was afraid and by combining
those two things together
he left the planet earth because he was
afraid of facing Franklin Richards now
this doesn't mean that Galactus and of
himself is terrified of the ability that
someone could have to work reality and
in fact this really is the case with
Franklin Franklin can morph reality but
it's the fact that Galactus is afraid of
Franklin because of the things he's done
in the past way back in the 1990s during
the Abraxas saga when Galactus was
killed
Abraxas took his place but then Franklin
Richards basically resurrected Galactus
from the dead the fact that he brought
back a cosmic entity from the dead tells
us how powerful Franklin is at the same
time Franklin's a child meaning that his
imagination can run wild you can create
and manifest all kinds of different
things that would wreak havoc on the
world as a whole and it could be that
Franklin doesn't know how to undo those
things so he could manifest some force
that would wipe out the universe
entirely and then not be able to undo
that we've never really seen an instance
where that's happened before but it
doesn't mean that it couldn't now while
we don't find out exactly what it was
that Galactus and Reed Richards talked
about instead Hickman actually just
skips over that now we'll find out
exactly what it is that he's talking
about once we see the mad celestial show
up and Franklin Richards battle them an
entire scenario effectively speaks for
itself but more so than that will
actually see Galactus speaking directly
to Franklin Richards about the power he
possesses and what it is that he's
capable of doing and how he relates to
Galactus himself but from here we
basically just show up at new earth and
we see the Galactus and Reed Richards
are talking about everything that's
going on and so where Galactus initially
asked how it was that new earth was
created how it was all this came into
existence again Reed Richards basically
rehashes what we know about the future
of the old man Logan universe and when
Galactus asks whether or not Reed
Richards can prevent this
happening that is to say he can
effectively save that future from coming
to an end
Reid begins to reflect on his time with
the with the Council of reeds and he
makes the case that yes most likely he
can solve this problem that would have
resulted in the destruction of the
future the result is that because Reid
would effectively be stopping those
individuals from the future and having
to come to the past in the first place
and initiate this entire series of
events for Galactus this world will
simply cease to exist and so instead of
allowing it to pass instead of allowing
it to basically vanish without any real
advantage Galactus decides to consume it
now one of my favorite things here is
that the occupants of new world
initially protests they say no Galactus
cannot destroy the world and Galactus
his reply is who tests God and does not
weigh to their life a price will be paid
and this is why I love Galactus so much
because this is just a cool thing to say
it's just a cool line to say I like the
way it sounds to be honest with you guys
and I might even make like a wallpaper
or something out of it but I think it's
a really cool moment it's just nothing
really significant here it's just these
are one of the things that I like about
about Hickman's writing and so basically
the people on this planet on new world
are given a chance to leave what
Galactus says is that he is going to
consume the world he's going to end all
of it but instead of simply just killing
all those individuals on new world what
he's going to do is allowed Reed
Richards to get as many people off the
planet as possible between the time that
Galactus begins consuming his machine in
order to consume the world and the time
that he's done doing that and so from
here what we do is we transition back to
the future of Franklin Richards and we
pick up with his character after he had
woken up the powers of his younger self
now I know this is a lot of
time-traveling I know this is a lot of
bouncing around but these things are
extremely important for understanding
the very end of this story and why
things unfold the way they do what
happens here is we pick up with the
adult Franklin Richards when you simply
arrives in the future and there's
nothing here it's just a giant expanse
of white we don't really know what's
going on here there's no planet there's
no greenery no buildings no nothing it's
just total emptiness and the questions
asked by an individual that we can't see
whether or not Franklin was successful
and what he says
is yes he had basically woken up the
powers of his younger self remove those
mental blocks and so now the younger
Franklin Richards has the power
what reality in addition to this the
adult Franklin Richards had told Valyria
that all hope lies in doom now we'll
find out why dr. doom is such an
important part of Jonathan Hickman's
Fantastic Four but what we learn is that
the adult version of Valyria is also
here alongside the adult version of
Franklin Richards and so what we're told
is that the entire basis behind this the
entire premise behind the adult Franklin
Richards going into the past was
performed by the father of Reed Richards
Nathanael now again when we started
Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four we had
talked about how the father of Reed
Richards Nathaniel Richards was
basically absent he threw out almost his
entire life he didn't really spend much
time talking to his son because he
wasn't there while he was part of Reed's
life when he was very very young
Nathanael had simply just vanished for
reasons that weren't really explained
what Hickman's run of the Fantastic Four
does is it basically fills in the gaps
and it simply says that at this point
all they can do is just see how things
unfold now again this is really just
very confusing here because the
indication seems to be now this future
is coming to an end and that some window
some opportunity is effectively closing
with each one with the passes and this
seems to be their last-ditch effort to
ensure that this future does not come to
fruition now again we don't really know
what this future is we just know that
something's going on and they're trying
to keep it from happening and so while
valaria travels back and she effectively
leaves what Franklin Richards does as an
adult is he manipulates this pocket
reality this little dementia that he's
created due to the fact that apparently
because the future is coming to an end
this is a safe space that time will
change time will pass but instead things
will stay exactly the way they are the
way he's making them within this small
space now this is all meta textual stuff
this is all meta textual commentary and
it can be a little bit daunting but
things will make sense and the reason
why is because Nathaniel Richards
actually jumps into the past to visit
Reed Richards when he was in college
alongside Ben Grimm and while they were
together while they were spending time
with one another what Nathaniel does is
he basically explains why he was gone
for so long what he says is that at some
point along the line
he and a multitude of other Nathaniel
Richards were pulled into a singularity
to battle some individual with immense
power and because of this
Nathaniel himself had gained the ability
to control time to manipulate time the
downside to this was that in the far
distant future time itself was
controlled by a man named immortus and
it was monitored by the time variance
authority meaning that individuals who
meddle with time are strictly punished
and so the result is that because both
Nathaniel Richards from the main Marvel
Universe and all the other alternate
reality versions of Nathaniel had all
developed the ability to manipulate time
after battling this foe they were all
brought forward to immortus and they
were basically instructed that not all
of them can have this power only one of
them can but because the power is part
of them on a genetic level it can't be
removed meaning the only way to ensure
that only one of them can have the power
is to eliminate every version of
Nathaniel Richards except for one and so
what this did is it initiated something
called the great hunt and it was
basically all these different versions
of Nathaniel Richards from across the
cosmos hunting each other down and
trying to kill each other and so for
those of you guys who read spire verse
and you followed the events with the
inheritors chasing down all the
different versions of spider-man and
spider-woman from across the multiverse
this is the equivalent of that except it
would be as if all the spider men were
hunting each other down and so what is
up happening is the Daniel petitions
Reed Richards to basically help him take
care of the last version of Nathaniel so
that the existing the main marvel
universe of Daniel Richards will be the
last one left now I'll read himself is
extremely intelligent during his college
years he's nowhere near as intelligent
as Doctor Doom now this will change over
time due to the fact that dr. Doom's
arrogance will actually get the better
of him but at the moment Reid is still
smart but doom knows a little bit more
about both technology and the ability to
manipulate time and so what ends up
happening is Nathaniel Richards and Ben
Grimm and Reed Richards and Doctor Doom
from the past from our college years
basically travel back into the future
and they encounter this second to last
remaining version of Nathaniel this evil
version of himself now where this isn't
super important where this isn't
necessarily the most important thing
coming out of the story it actually is
the basis for why Franklin Richards is
doing the things that he's doing and
what we find out here is
with these versions of Nathaniel
battling one another ultimately it all
comes down to this very notion of
Nathaniel is going to be the last one
left he essentially kills all the other
versions of himself and so with these
two versions of Nathaniel Richards
battling one another the conflict
essentially goes exactly the way that we
would suspect in the sense that there is
some give-and-take there's the
possibility that the main version of the
Thane yo Richard will lose but
ultimately he ends up coming out on top
with the help of Reed Richards Ben Grimm
and Doctor Doom from the past and so
while they're successful in killing this
other version of himself
Nathaniel Richards is basically the last
one left now the main version of
Nathaniel Richards is the only iteration
of himself now having said that what we
do now is we pick up with Nathaniel
travelling back to the future to meet
Franklin Richards and this is extremely
important and if there's nothing else
that you remember from the story please
remember this what is up happening here
is that Franklin begins to talk with
Nathaniel and he asks him were you
successful in killing that other version
of yourself and Nathaniel says yes and
so the result is that Franklin says
perfect and destroys the reality around
Nathaniel and what this does is it tells
us that Nathaniel himself is almost
powerless to stop everything that's
going on that he doesn't even really
understand why it is that Franklin's
doing this and what Franklin says is
that one he disabled the ability of
Nathaniel to use his own powers by
controlling both reality around him and
manipulating his brain but also that
when Nathaniel engaged in the great hunt
and began killing off all the other
versions of himself that he made all
those alternate reality versions of Reed
Richards fatherless and the reason why
this is a big deal is because in our
earlier versions of Hickman's run a
fantastic four we had talked about how
those alternate reality versions of Reed
Richards had created the Council of
reeds and abandoned their families
because they didn't have the guidance of
their fathers and the reason they didn't
have the guidance of their fathers is
because this great hunt took place and
their fathers were killed off and so
what Franklin is doing here is he's not
really gaining revenge on Nathaniel he's
basically saying that Nathaniel Eden or
himself is the reason why all this
happened in the first place and so what
we do and something you may have noticed
as we were going through this comic is
we actually saw some discussion between
valaria and Susan and we pick
with that while there is a lot of fluff
that goes on and the two of them talking
which is really just a mother relating
to her daughter where at least valaria
relating to her mother in her younger
form not everything that happens here is
extremely important and in fact the only
thing that's really important is what
she says to Susan storm at the end what
valaria tells her is that when
everything seems like it's darkest when
everything seems like it's going to end
and all hope seems to be gone that Susan
storm is going to have to hold on she's
going to have to keep fighting despite
the fact that the circumstances seem
bleak but at the moment that she does
that at the time when everything seems
like it's going to crack and it's gonna
fall to pieces that something will come
to save her now we find out what that
something is again at the end of this
story I know it seems really really wild
but uh but this yeah it's it's it's
awesome what happens I'm almost inclined
to spoil it because I've done it before
but I don't really want to those of you
guys who have read Hickman's Fantastic
Four please don't spoil this please
don't tell people what happens
but in the end winds up happening is
that hilarya effectively departs as
things begin to come to a close she
takes off and she goes back with
Franklin Richards and what we find out
is that something had happened in the
past to began this wave of destruction
throughout the multiverse and the
multiverse itself was effectively
collapsing and this pocket universe that
Franklin had made was designed to keep
space-time separate from around them but
the issue with this is that Franklin
himself can warp reality but in order
for him to be able to warp it he has to
be in control of it and the issue is
that if reality is operating outside of
his control he can't do anything to stop
it his powers effectively work against
him and that seems to be what's
happening here and so was the two of
them begin to get sucked into this rift
what is up happening is they jump
through and then we actually won't see
or hear from them until the very end of
this story but with that being said
we're going to go ahead and wing this
video to an end let me go let me know
what you guys think about about Hickman
instead hazard for again as of the last
video I know this can be a little bit
daunting if these will actually be a lot
easier to understand going forward but
again I promise
all of this will make sense once we get
to the end and that's the nature of a
Hickman story Hickman stories draw
threads from all
over the place they pull threads from
everywhere and nothing seems to make
sense but then at the very very end he
writes a single comic that wraps all
that stuff up and then you just get the
light bulb effect
oh I understand what he was doing that's
exactly what is up happening so don't
worry guys everything will make sense at
the end of this which will probably
happen in the next three or four videos
or so we've got a few more things to
cover especially with the death of
Johnny Storm in the future of Ben Grimm
but aside from that we can actually sort
of jump towards the end and then just
fill things in according to whatever
seems to be interesting but but yeah I'm
gonna go ahead and add this video up and
I will catch you guys later peace